when it premiered on ABC in September of
1993 NYPD Blue made television history
with its gritty portrayal of the
exploits of Manhattan's 15th Police
Precinct using documentary style camera
work and a healthy dose of pg-13
material creators Steven Bochco and
David Milch assured network television
into a bold new era of creative
storytelling during its 12 season run
the show formed a solid ensemble of
talented actors many of whom got their
big break on the critically acclaimed
series let's look back at some of the
most notable NYPD Blue cast members and
discover what they've been up to since
turning in their badges David Caruso
prior to busting perp says detective
John Kelly David Caruso had a solid
career from playing a cop in Rambo first
blood to playing a gang leader in ba
Chico's groundbreaking series Hill
Street Blues the success of NYPD Blue
launched Caruso on to the a-list and he
famously left the show after the first
season to star in forgettable films like
kiss of death which pretty much
described Caruso's attempts at
big-screen stardom Caruso revitalized
his career by returning the TV for 10
seasons of CSI Miami as lieutenant
horatio Caine his penchant for puns and
dark sunglasses achieved pretty epic
meme status Brin said she came down to
drink mojitos and catch her son looks
like something caught her Caruso has
kept a low profile since CSI Miami ended
in 2012 Steven Bochco later opened up
about his tumultuous working
relationship with Caruso calling the
stars behavior on the NYPD blue set
cancerous and alleging he had outrageous
demands like $100,000 per episode and a
38-foot trailer Dennis Franz though he's
forever associated with cantankerous
recovering alcoholic detective Andy
Sipowicz Franz previously played the
equally irritable lieutenant Norman
Bunce on Hill Street Blues and it's
forgotten fish-out-of-water comedy
spin-off Beverly Hills buntz as Sipowicz
Franz scored four Emmys and one
memorable nude shower scene following
NYPD Blues final season Franz left
showbiz to focus on a quiet life that
presumably doesn't involve smacking
suspects with phone books he resurfaced
at the 2016 Emmys reuniting with former
co-star Jimmy Smits to the delight of
fans maybe it's time for Netflix to
greenlight Sipowicz the frickin golden
years
Jimmy Smits la lost our Jimmy Smits
joined the cast of NYPD Blue in season
two is Sipowicz his partner Bobby Simone
after Caruso's John Kelly resigned from
the force
Simone's tragic death from a heart
condition made for one of the most
moving episodes of the series Smits on
the other hand is alive and well and
recently appeared as Senator Donovan on
24 legacy Smits also have memorable runs
on shows like The West Wing sons of
anarchy and Dexter he also returned to
the character he played in the Star Wars
prequels senator Bail Organa for 2016's
hitfilm wrote one with the best role
he's ever played Johnny Wilson conky
repairman on pee-wee's Playhouse Johnny
Wilson authorized conky repairman at
your service miss Yvonne is that a
wrench in your pocket that's a wrench
thank you very much Kim Delaney actress
Kim Delaney brought grit to the role of
Detective Diane Russell whose battles
with alcoholism and tumultuous
relationships with fellow cops made for
some juicy storylines the part earned
Delaney an Emmy for Best Supporting
Actress after leaving blue Delaney took
the lead role on Steven Bochco
short-lived legal drama Philly and had a
brief run opposite David Caruso on CSI
Miami following six seasons on the
lifetime series army wives Delaney again
reunited with Bosco for a role on his
TNT series murder in the first
mark-paul Gosselaar fans were surprised
when Zack Morris himself mark-paul
Gosselaar joined NYPD Blue in season 9
as a replacement for departed cast
member Rick Schroder
Hustler's detective John Clark held his
own opposite the cast and remained with
the show until it came to an end in 2005
who knew Gosselaar would prove to be the
best actor among the Bayside Bunch with
roles on everything from Franklin & bash
to the Fox baseball series pitch
Gosselaar has remained a reliable
presence on the small screen
he also relived his giant cell phone
coding days and a Saved by the Bell
reunion on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon
Gordon clap with his constant motormouth
and awkward demeanor detective Greg
Medavoy brought comic relief to the 15th
precinct a regular on NYPD Blue
throughout its entire run Medavoy grew
to be a fan favorite and an Emmy winner
gordon clap continues to work in theatre
earning a Tony nomination for Glengarry
Glen Ross on Broadway and on shows like
damages and elementary these days he has
a recurring role as chaplain Orlovsky on
Chicago Fire
Nicholas Turturro John saturos younger
brother made a name for himself on NYPD
Blue scoring an Emmy nomination for his
role as detective James Martinez
Martinez was a crucial part of the squad
before being promoted to sergeant in
season 7 in saying goodbye to the 15th
precinct - Turo returned to the blue
brotherhood for his role as sergeant
Renzulli on CBS's blue bloods and his
voice can be heard as the ghostly
superhero Deadman in the Justice League
dark animated movie me it's heard of me
sweet he also showed off his comedic
chops in films like paul blart mall cop
2 and bucky larson born to be a star
James McDaniel as lieutenant Arthur
fancy James McDaniel held the 15th
precinct together with his calm yet
commanding presence eventually being
promoted to captain McDaniel left the
show after season 8 and while the
precinct had other captains they don't
hold a candle to McDaniel with the deep
resume that includes theatrical
productions and films like Malcolm X and
TV shows like Sleepy Hollow and The Good
Wife McDaniel has kept busy since
hanging up his gun and shield he also
has the dubious distinction of having
starred on Steven Bochco infamous
musical police procedural pop rock and
rock it did not
Henry Simmons joining blue in its
seventh season as meta voice new partner
Baldwin Jones Henry Simmons was one-half
of a formidable team with Jones's
intensity and meta voice persistence
working in tandem to get confessions out
of skills
Simmons is currently part of the Marvel
TV universes Mack on agents of shield
you may have also caught him on shows
like Ravenswood and man up build rocked
row as PAA upstairs John Irvin bill
brock trip brought heart diversity and
subtle humor to what could have been a
thankless forgettable role prior to Blue
Rock trip was a regular on Steven Bochco
shows like total security and the doomed
cop comedy public morals these days
Brock Tripp keeps busy in the theater
world and brings the same sensitivity he
brought to Jon to his role as
psychologist dr. Bowman on TNT's major
crimes Sharon Lawrence a DA Sylvia
Costas was on the receiving end of one
of Sipowicz his most memorably profane
rants in the pilot episode of NYPD Blue
but she eventually fell for his gruff
charms and married the old lug her
murder during season six left Sipowicz
to raise their infant son alone actress
Sharon Lawrence who scored three Emmy
nominations for her role
the series in 1996 to co-star with Leah
Remini on the short-lived NBC sitcom
fired up a TV vet she's had memorable
roles on shows like Desperate Housewives
Grey's Anatomy and shameless Charlotte
Ross prior to NYPD Blue Charlotte Ross
cut her teeth in the soap opera world
and starred on the short-lived Fox
musical drama The Heights she joined the
cop drama in 2001 and made a splash when
her character detective Connie McDowell
appeared partially nude in a
controversial 2004 episode the
sweet-natured McDowell would eventually
melt grumpy ol Sipowicz his heart and
the pair married and raised kids in the
show's later seasons Ross has kept busy
on television since blue ended with
turns on shows like Glee and Nashville
arrow fans will recognize her as
felicity Smoak's brassy mom Donna on the
hit CW superhero show thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]